[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
come on guys we're feeling the buzz
let's make it happen all right here it
is Cheers Cheers no alcohol to now 31
days gentlemen we [ __ ] did one yes to
all you out there too did it with us
cheers
[Music]
oh that's good scotch
21 year old Glenn livett very nice damn
let me just say that I look forward to
this so much I really do
foreign
things I come out of them with like a
newfound appreciation for our friendship
a newfound appreciation for the fun and
you're doing it you'll do it for one
month
and everyone's gonna shoot up we can
talk [ __ ] to each other and have so much
fun it is it's so much fun that's
[ __ ] so ridiculous it's so dumb for
19 750 calories I've done 2400 push-ups
zero drinks zero drugs
this is fun times this is like what I
miss Joe Rogan Tom Segura Ari shafir and
Bert Chrysler capped off yet another
successful sober October on Tuesday with
the whole game going on The Joe Rogan
Experience to talk about their results
from the month they discuss what they
liked and disliked from this year's
Challenge and even talked about another
sober October type event that they might
do sometime soon I'd be interested if we
should all do it but I'm coming I would
like to do another thing what like this
another challenge like a thousand like
like a hundred squats a day or air
squats just something so that I have to
pay a taxi actually we should do that we
should we should come up with that today
and I think because you asked for it we
should definitely challenge you to
something we can all do it but I'm
saying challenge me to what like you're
saying an additional challenge should be
first yeah pretty cool I can't get
involved in competition no no not like
challenge like sort of like like it
wasn't your brain you know your brain's
adjacent to mine right I'm sure they're
neighbors they're next door neighbors
and they both both don't like it and who
moved in across the street that well
that's why I get so upset when you talk
[ __ ] I got a challenge Bert's gonna be
on board you guys are gonna be nut we do
rowing the rowing thing we finish it off
with doing the talisker cross Atlantic
Journey four-person row you're sucking
the devil's dick right now I love your
brain I love your pain Tommy and I are
going to be live broadcasting I love
your brains it would be from live from
your mom's house
it's like two three days
three weeks Jamie
Grace
the whole time I love this and you knew
he would love that [ __ ] of course I love
this I love it I called it perfectly I
love it across the Atlantic some of us
[ __ ] love this every day we take we
take two and two two and two this is the
best idea right it's a terrible idea and
you get all we all see if we can row
across the Atlantic yes
I've ever [ __ ] hurt I'm gonna miss
you guys
you know what I hate about you what you
knew to [ __ ] send this to dum-dums
this is better than my teaser this is
the best thing I've ever seen the [ __ ]
out of here besides setting health
related goals with one another the crew
is also discussing doing a sober October
stand-up show next year or at least some
sort of big event next time they're all
together in Austin which if they did go
on some sort of tour together that would
honestly be one of the best shows all
year one of the craziest lineups that
you could see outside of going to a
legendary comedy club like the store or
the comedy seller it'd be rare to find a
lineup that talented those big of names
anywhere my goal next year is on the
fully loaded tour to get in shape where
I can hit dingers one after another I
want to hit like 15 home runs dangers
Wow real baseball shape he's playing
baseball stadiums yeah I'm doing
baseball stadiums but I want to hit home
run after home run after home run so
someone throws a pitch in front of the
whole crowd and you hit a home run and
then you do your show no no no no no no
after hours after the games the teams
really show up do batting practice and I
am I'm watching the shows oh yeah I do
have videos fully loaded tour coming
next year tour [ __ ] yeah amazing it's
the funnest and
hardcore secret time
and we're doing one in Austin and I
would love for you guys to be a part of
it when is that okay what's up
I'm so bad at this can I suggest
something please I really think it's on
you guys not on me what it is September
we should do some massive shows
uh Joe and Tom will like headline Bert
can MCL parked cars
but like let's do some [ __ ] wild
massive shows over October shows let's
do them yeah September is
you you too I guess especially the big
one is can you clear September I have a
week that I'm not clearing out in
September yeah elk hunting season
we'll talk about it we'll talk about it
afterwards but can we do that yeah we
could do something I mean we'll throw it
afterwards I don't want to put you guys
we 100 could do something and we could
also do celebration in November we could
do we could do that the highlight of the
sober October podcast Episode by far was
when they all maxed out their push-ups
specifically when Rogan claimed he could
do double whatever Bert does this felt
like more of the old-fashioned sober
October with the constant [ __ ] talking
and Rogan losing his mind literally
becoming furious with Bert because of
all his Larger than Life claims that
just aren't true or aren't even based in
reality so that was a good part of the
episode when they were really going at
it felt like old times the problem with
winners and losers is I'm crazy yep and
uh you're crazy and Bert's an [ __ ]
but it I just don't I don't like that
that part I don't want to open up that
[ __ ] box in my brain it's not what
part of you doesn't get my sense of
humor it's not that I don't get it I
don't care
you don't understand you think I don't
get it oh I know what you're doing I'm
like not with me [ __ ]
who do you think could do the most
push-ups right now in a row definitely
me you want me to start sure whatever
you do I'll do double don't say that how
many can you do in a row easy 40. he'll
think I could do 80.
prove it prove it prove it
20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 31 32
33. by the way none of those count oh
[ __ ] none of those are legit all right
not a single one not a single one was
legitimate oh come on
50.
50. all right you're good man
he's got to do 66.
so it's brain right all right 70. 70
keep going five more five more five more
four
five
wow dude [ __ ] nice
how many was that 70 75 push-ups wow 75
oh pretty impressive wow Tucker Carlson
can't do that I didn't hurt myself
I was legitimately worried for real yeah
I was gonna like I was gonna go too far
75 is a lot
good job Joe thanks
overall it seemed like everyone
benefited from this year's sober October
and had a good time doing it
surprisingly even Ari who historically
has been very against sober October even
he was saying he enjoyed the results
from this year and wants to keep it
going I think the biggest departure from
regular life for any of us is actually
for you this month because we're
actually I mean he's obviously a lunatic
and then we are active but you don't do
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're like you're like oh
my God I did the stairs today so the
stairs in my apartment it was like I
gotta just I gotta do this at 1am yeah
you work out like that homeless guy you
were talking about
what are you doing they're going in the
laundry room and I'm like so wait are
you gonna stick to any of it you think I
I'm gonna try to do
shirtless what I like to use shirtless
flexing if I had to if I had to bet I'd
say no that guy's not gonna stick with
it but in my head I'm like three days a
week would be nice you should do it and
especially if you're like 500 is a
normal you can it's not crazy you can
say it's not just working out randomly
you're gonna feel better
because I know there were some problem
areas your problem errors are gone
when I had to trade Roger Waters asset
for sit-ups but here's the thing if you
can keep doing this you can keep that
and you could even get better
smell if you can keep working out like
just I mean that 500 a day is not that
[ __ ] hard it's really not it's about
45 minutes yeah it's about 45 minutes if
you're doing stuff hard where your heart
rate's jacked and if you're doing like
weight lifting it's probably like an
hour and a half yeah but it's not that
hard and the benefit of like the lack of
anxiety is [ __ ] extraordinary I don't
know how you guys are my anxiety is so
far down my skin is better my my crowd
work is at an all-time high your brain's
up firing different uh-huh and it's like
I think that you need that I think we're
supposed that's what humans are supposed
to do they're supposed to have physical
activity in their life especially in
their 30s like this like you're supposed
to like like get after it I also you can
do normal things we don't all have
access to the [ __ ] Madison Square
Garden you know workout gym that bird
has and [ __ ] like that but like we can
all do I can just jump on a city bike
and bike for 40 minutes
staircase you just would walk stairs
it's also that thing where like the
older you get at the more resources you
have and the easier you can make life
and like when you force yourself to be
uncomfortable workouts can sometimes be
the only uncomfortable part of your day
yeah you know that's it that's very
important very uncomfortable all the
time and coming home at 1am going I'm
done and like [ __ ] I know these [ __ ]
[ __ ] are my friends I gotta do this
[ __ ] I'm done yeah but you're one of
those [ __ ] too bro you are true
I feel a little like blamed because like
you blame us while you're doing this
thing that you agreed to we all agreed
to it imagine it'd be drugged you
there's a powerful thing moving forward
we'll definitely be keeping a close eye
on this big show we're tour that these
guys are talking about potentially doing
next year that sounds [ __ ] sweet dude
like if you're watching this video right
now I'd assume that you'd also really
want to go to a stand-up show of sagora
Rogan Bert and Ari all performing
together well if you don't want to miss
out on that and you want to be
constantly in the loop with all about
comedy news and the whole comedy world
all at once consider subscribing to this
Channel right now joke world for all
your comedy news and needs literally
everything happening in the whole comedy
scene all in one YouTube channel doesn't
get much better than that please
subscribe it would really help out the
channel follow us on Instagram and thank
you so much for watching this video
um we'll see you again Monday with the
comedy news but seriously thanks for
watching thank you for supporting the
brand and yeah call me news Monday have
a good weekend
[Music]
foreign